[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we could do it even live Ted he could do
it folks crazy Bernie
Foca hottest she could do it and even
that lying filthy [ __ ] Hillary Clinton
she could do it folks second was better
yeah okay I was thank yourself for the
documentary instance yeah this is how
this works when we forgot to bring a
microphone you're new around here so
I'll go easy on you
[Music]
what are you run away things will get
better proportionate faintly brother
buddy
photos we gotta make a dead girl work
here
[Music]
we'll get better fortunately this same
I'm gonna like mill here
[Music]
[Applause]
Detroit City I said welcome to Detroit
City every place everywhere we go
yeah they pitch trying to ban our show
but it's going down in Detroit city
louder with Crowder in Detroit City Oh
Ann Arbor's in the light like a suburb
[Applause]
734 it's kind of its own thing
hey now welcome to a two City I said
welcome to a two city every place
everywhere we go yeah they wanna try to
ban our show but we're here now an a to
city louder with Crowder an a to city
schmitt trick poets as soon as I hit the
road you can hear me in this [ __ ]
[Applause]
it's gonna be very uneven Baga helmets
you know I really big comic book fans
yes there's in the comic-con leagues
suggest Caitlin's involvement in the
newly announced plotline Santos the
intergalactic trans folk so that seems
really sorry you saw in the posters my
good friend Owen Benjamin was supposed
to be here tonight but he couldn't make
it because a family affair too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I wanted to know why you call this a
terrorist password because it's funny
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is absolutely your civic duty to speak
the truth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
TRT jr. and the whole true
michigan loves you we appreciate you to
appropriate is to appreciate
[Applause]
hey there YouTube viewer if you like
this video I would say subscribe hit the
notification bell or watch one of these
videos playing in a box that we've
personally uploaded in program for your
viewing pleasure the problem is now in
today's day and age on YouTube in 2018
any of those three things that you do
any of those three buttons that you
click will take you directly to a Seth
Meyers video so stay here and join my
get off of here go to let accredited
come slash buckle up it's the only safe
place you can go enjoy